Jordan Palmer former NFL quarterback now
quarterback coach for Sam darn old and
Josh Allen he was there for the pro day
yesterday what is your role what has
been your role with Sam Donald well you
know I met Sam at a young age and he's
kind of from where I'm from and so as I
was playing and finishing out my NFL
career and he was coming up through the
ranks I'm involved with a program called
elite 11 Trent Dilfer runs and big Nike
initiative and we you know we could
let's see about a thousand high school
kids every year and then Whittle it down
in the top 11 better program been around
for a long time he kind of filtered
through that program and so I just kind
of was kind of big-brother role and then
the last couple months as I put him
through my drop training program we were
able to go ahead and kind of expedite
the process of him becoming a pro and
get him ready for not just the
interviews in the combine and what
happened yesterday but really getting
him ready to play as a rookie
why didn't he throw at the combine you
know I think a kid like that with all
the different opportunities that he's
going to have to be able to impress
teams and and you know being able to
focus in meetings and go ahead and run
and then throw on your pro day and then
compartmentalize and separate the time
and the focus into the private meetings
was kind of a team around him the
decisions they made the how to handle
that and and I think you did really well
in each face so far did you advise him
to not throw it to combine no I really
stay out of that I own it's important as
these guys build their teams around them
from an agent marketing and trainer I
really stay in my lane and so I don't
really have a ton of input on that but I
I think there's there's merit to
throwing there's merits and not throwing
you know I've heard a plenty of front
office guys say man I really want these
guys to throw this was my kid I probably
would tell him not to
he's a first-round pick I was curious
yesterday is anything changed with his
delivery and maybe it's so subtle that
we wouldn't pick it up but you're
working with him Donald so has his
delivery changed
there's just there's some subtle things
that you're not going to see on a
highlight than yesterday you know with
Sam I'm not a believer that that there's
one way to throw it I think there's a
most efficient way for each person to
throw it and Sam has a couple things
that are unique in terms of you don't
people call it a loop or what everybody
has released the ball coming down a
little bit at the same time it's he's
actually quicker than pretty much
everybody else the ball comes understand
really really quick and so what I tried
to do is change some of his posture
which may sound really subtle but if you
change the posture and he was pretty
hunched over but he stands really tall
now and what you're not doing is
recruiting your chest muscles so when
you go to throw you're not just throwing
a ball arm you get to recruit the whole
front side of your body and what that
does is that one you're gonna get more
more energy on the ball but soon you're
also going to take a lot of stress off
of your your bicep tendon your tricep
tendon those types of things and you
know I'm the younger brother Karsan who
the last five years battled elbow issues
and elbow tendonitis and so I get to
look at it from a different vantage
point and even if these kids don't have
an elbow or shoulder injury from
throwing I really want to get with them
early on and take that pressure and put
it across as many muscles as we can and
not just on their elbow or their
shoulder so there's so it's more
preventative maintenance down the road
is that the locks and Arnold's going to
the Browns you know I don't know I would
I would feel that way but I'm not here
in Laramie Wyoming
I'm gonna run Josh Allen's pro day
tomorrow and as easy of it as a decision
that would be to take Sam with the whole
body of work Dan I mean this this kid
Josh Allen is like maybe the most
talented dude I've ever seen
what I mean sighs arm talent how also
just how intelligent he is the type of
person he is
so you know he's from a smaller school
and he sounded really interesting route
no offers JUCO Wyoming you know Sam and
most drafts I think's a lot to be number
one but obviously I'm not gonna sit here
and pick one but I think that Josh is
gonna do so well tomorrow that it's kind
of really interesting okay but if you're
the Cleveland
who would you take knowing what the
Cleveland Browns are and what they have
so wait I know you love both of them
Josh Allen and Sam darn 'old but who is
best for Cleveland in your opinion you
know I don't know enough about exactly
what Cleveland needs and I'm gonna be
really honest with you yeah I figured I
you know you shook off the the sign
there from the from the catcher so all
right I get that
so Josh Allen's got more talent than any
other quarterback you seen yeah you know
I played with Carson in his prime I
played with Cutler comes armed Talent
and this doesn't necessarily means he's
the best I've ever seen right just in
terms of arm talent and his abilities I
hadn't really seen anything like it and
I was even people want to talk about
JaMarcus Russell we were ball boys look
together at the elite 11 we were
counselors in college at the elite 11
twice we were the same draft bus I
played a lot of cash with DeMarcus in
his prime yeah this dude it's just he
creates so much energy and it's so
effortless and I mean he's you know he's
nice and trim for the combine but I mean
he's gonna be a little play at 2:45 and
he's really fast too and he can stop and
start so how far is he and I'm actually
really excited to see III at the end of
the pro days I have them kind of move
around flip the other direction set up
and I have somebody run like a curl and
then the quarterback runs around I have
that guy who stopped running his curl
and take off just as far as you can up
across the field I don't know I mean he
may throw at 80 yards tomorrow we'll see
I don't want to hype it up too much but
I mean Sam threw it 65 so I'm like that
70 maybe yesterday and at the end of the
workout I don't know how far Joshua
throat but he's gonna tell everybody
tomorrow if I put the over-under at 82
yards when you taken that's actually a
great over/under I think I'm taking it
over just what the juice starts flow
yeah you know indoor it's not gonna rain
on us tomorrow no I know I'm taking you
over
Jordan Palmer's joining us the
Continental Tire Coach's Corner the
quarterback coach you know throwing in
the rain I think a lot was made of that
I mean it's still a pro day it's
scripted I don't know what you glean
from these pro days what what would you
take away because you were you were the
one hosting this setting this up you
know to have this Pro day with Sam
darling
what what should I take away with that
performance or is it that or is it just
his demeanor personality one no I think
I mean I'm gonna be really honest and
the guy running these pro days and I
actually think it's one of the least
relevant portions of the process the
relevant part of it is that it's a
really big day he has to throw well
every he isn't the person throwing that
day everybody's watching it's one of
those dynamics we've got your former
teammates you have your family you have
the last time you'll do anything with
this school and then you have your
future staring at you watching you and
so it's just a really pressure filled
day and if I was an evaluator I just
want to see how they handled the entire
process the whole day because for a lot
of quarterbacks they're really talented
and every year you know anything you
would have done your list of busts
usually it's not talent usually it's the
lights were too bright for that dude and
that is something you can tell Sam
yesterday did not flinch with the rain
everybody was there all of his idols
Aikman grew up hitting the only young
kid he grew up idolizing Matt Leinart
all of everybody's there and all the
team's the owner Jimmy Haslam sitting
with his parents in the stands and he
handled it really really really well I
mean he's gonna be a hall-of-famer
absolutely not but it's another example
of him having a bunch of pressure on him
and handling a ball did you first work
out with Blake bortles yeah I mean my
start was I was backing out I was in
Chicago Flynn to the Bears and I was
speaking at the rookie symposium and I
was talking to some Ricky quarterbacks
and I couldn't believe that they just
got done training for the draft and they
didn't know anything I was like next
year I'm training somebody for the draft
so I called exos which is the facility
that all the top players were going to
and I was like let me train here this
offseason a little bit of cash and I'll
try and get your rookie dudes ready to
pull
and I don't know what to combine all
getting ready to play what did you make
of Chris sim saying bortles is the
seventieth the best quarterback in the
NFL it's funny you know I think I think
having a take you got these guys that
are polarizing Blake's one of them and I
actually with Blake because I know his I
mean it's a you know it's like my little
brother and the mental makeup and all
that stuff I think he totally fuels off
that stuff he loves it he's always loved
doubters there's other guys where you'd
go oh man I hope he doesn't hear that
you know Blake is uh Blake's a fighter
and I think he just loves that stuff one
doesn't care one more item I want to go
back to the Bengals they were on Hard
Knocks and you were there with your
brother Carson there was an app that you
guys were talking about I don't think
you talked about it more than 15 seconds
but it was called run P app which tells
you when to use the bathroom during any
movie right yeah yeah Carson had nothing
to do with it it's so funny right so it
that would be my your entire career day
and all the things you've done and I'm
like you're the guy that played
saxophone at Lincoln Middle School right
this thing I did for a minute
there and into a lottery do you still
have a lottery ticket yeah we uh yeah I
mean we we my two buddies I started out
with I wanted to learn business as a
rookie in the league and we and the app
market hadn't even come out yet I was
one of the first apps and we did it we
made apps for a bunch of athletes and we
made an app called before Instagram that
was essentially Instagram and we had 9
million daily active users we raised a
ton of capital and then pivoted and now
shots is the name of the business and
it's actually one of the biggest
channels on YouTube and it's a content
creation company in the studio so it's
actually it was my way to learn business
and we just kept pivoting as apps that
was the wild wild west when we created
apps the guy who built that for us there
was only two people in the state of
California who knew how to make an app
so really that was so for us it was R&D
and it was great way for me to learn
business and I've got a bunch of really
cool business stuff going on now aside
from all the
whole stuff and actually that dumb app
was the thing that got me excited about
entrepreneurship and business but there
is so there was an app called they it
can I still find this that I can use
this app to tell me when to use the
bathroom during any movie I don't know
okay how about it yeah it was great
though I mean it was really funny is the
feedback we got on pregnant women in
London I think it was like Oprah's
Favorite Things or some Ellen ever hits
some some big talk show and it was all
these pregnant women loved it because it
was you know very helpful so you'd have
somebody somebody would go through all
these movies and say alright at this
point go take a bathroom break yeah all
right apps no one knew what they were
it's right what's up what's a funny
website we concern it and there was a
guy named dam who sit in the movie and
we write it down
and so we made the app and you would hit
it start at the beginning and it would
tell you when to go the bathroom and
then afterwards what you met that's
great
have fun on Friday with Josh it's always
great to talk to you Jordan we
appreciate that and tell of course and
we sit alone well thank you
Jordan Palmer elite quarterback coach he
trains Sam Donald John Shaolin and
that's when Seaton goes well we gotta
ask about the run P app I go what it
goes yeah you remember that where you
could take a bathroom break and they
would tell you when you could take a
bathroom break when you're watching a
movie every time ever since that hard
knocks which was years ago
yeah I would watch a movie man I should
add that nap
well Pauly did this when the movie get
out didn't you yeah bad timing you you
missed a really important pivotal role
moment there a my bladder I have hell
and I miss the most important two
minutes of it Continental Tire coaches
corner whether you're a student alumni
are all around fan continental tire has
a tire that can get you to the big game
and did you know that they're a proud
supporter of 32 college basketball teams
they'd like to know what your passion
for the game is show them your passion
using the hashtag ode to basketball for
more information visit Continental Tire
dot-com for more Dan Patrick show to the
it's channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]